ziel offene grenzen ab samstag
kontrolliert die bundespolizei nur noch
stichprobenartig urlaubsreisen in
nachbarländer sollen aber erst ab mitte
juni möglich sein
kein urlaub keine einnahmen der
reiseveranstalter tui streicht wegen der
pandemie tausende stellen
die branche fordert hilfe und
infektionsherd schlachtbetriebe immer
mehr corona fälle werfen ein schlaglicht
auf die arbeitsbedingungen die
bundesregierung will nachbessern
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievert in allen danke dass
sie bei uns sind hier ist die welt an
diesem mittwoch eine welt die wieder
grenzenloser werden soll
in kleinen vorsichtigen schritten ab 15
juni will deutschland seine grenzen
wieder offen haben und die kontrollen
beenden das ist nicht nur eine nachricht
für alle urlauber sondern auch für
berufspendler und ein zeichen an eine
milliarden branche die unter den cola
beschränkungen ganz besonders leidet wir
beginnen heute abend mit dem überblick
über die situation von julia schröter
deutschlands außengrenzen schritt für
schritt werden sie wieder durchlässiger
zuerst luxemburg dort fallen die
grenzkontrollen in der nacht zu samstag
komplett weg genauso könnte es aus
deutscher sicht auch an der grenze zu
dänemark laufen
dort gibt es allerdings noch
verhandlungen mit den dänen an den
grenzen zu frankreich der schweiz und
österreich wird ab samstag zumindest
gelockert
es werden alle grenzübergänge geöffnet
auch kleine kontrollen gibt es weiterhin
aber nur noch stichprobenartig und nicht
mehr systematisch wie bisher ab dem 15
juni sollen die grenzkontrollen dann
ganz wegfallen
sofern die infektionszahlen niedrig
bleiben statt systematischer kontrollen
also nur noch stichproben sagt heute der
bundesinnenminister der in den letzten
tagen unter druck gekommen war die
grenzen auch wieder zu öffnen
er empfiehlt den bundesländern jetzt die
regel aufzuheben nach der bisher auch
jeder der aus einem europäischen
nachbarland nach deutschland zurückreist
erst mal 14 tage in quarantäne muss die
politische diskussion beschreibt andreas
ruppert
die deutsch französische grenze
noch ist hier carola bedingt die ein und
ausreise stark eingeschränkt das bleibt
erstmal auch die nächsten vier wochen so
danach allerdings soll es gelockert
werden so der bundesinnenminister
wir verbinden dies mit der klaren
zielsetzung dass wir dann ab mitte juni
den freien reiseverkehr in europa wieder
wollen und das auch anstreben wenn es
die infektions lage zulässt werden für
frankreich österreich und die schweiz
alle grenzübergreifenden
verkehrsverbindungen wieder aufgemacht
allerdings gilt erst einmal bis zum 15
juni weiterhin keine einreise ohne
triftigen grund zum beispiel beruflich
oder familie nur zum spaß oder gar um
urlaub zu machen dafür gelten die
lockerungen nicht im bundestag mahnte
die kanzlerin weiter zur vorsicht
es wäre doch deprimierend wenn wir weil
wir zu schnell zu viel wollen wieder zu
einschränkungen zurückkehren müssten die
wir alle hinter uns lassen wollen
lassen sie uns also mutig und wachsam
seien keine zu frühen hoffnungen auf
unbeschwerten sommer urlaub also die afg
kam mit den angekündigten grenzöffnungen
leben in allen ländern in denen das
gesundheitssystem ähnlich funktioniert
und die ähnliche maßnahme kräften haben
also das gilt zb für österreich ist das
kein problem für die linke braucht
allerdings mehr als nur lockerungen beim
grenzverkehr
ich plädiere dafür dass man mindestens
dieselbe intensität auch bei der
eröffnung von kitas denn es kann nicht
sein
grenzen aufgeht dazu das ist ein
widerspruch die bundesregierung hat auch
beschlossen wer aus einem nachbarland
ein reist braucht künftig nicht die
bisher vorgeschriebene 14-tägige
quarantäne einhalten aussetzung auch
hier wie für alle lockerungen die
infektions lage lässt es zu da muss noch
mal reden die meisten grenzen bleiben
für urlauber also erstmal zu aber
gleichzeitig kommt auch die botschaft
wir kontrollieren das nicht mehr
intensiv theo koll guten amt was ist das
für ein signal nach berlin kommt meines
erachtens ist das erst mal eine
mogelpackung um ehrlich zu sein motto
der grenzübertritt bleibt zwar verboten
aber wir schauen jetzt nicht mehr so
genau hin optisch werden die
absperrungen und auch die staus vor den
grenzübergängen verschwinden aber
ansonsten ist es keine weitere öffnung
denn der kreis der reise berechtigten
also berufspendler güterverkehr oder
menschen mit triftigem grund wird ja
erst einmal nicht erweitert kleine
weitere ausnahme gruppen sollen erst
noch
verarbeitet werden für alle anderen
bleibt es weitere vier wochen bei den
bestehenden einschränkungen ausnahmen
sind reisen nach luxemburg und
vielleicht bald auch dänemark erst mitte
juni dann könnten sich die grenzen
wirklich öffnen und auch das nur wenn
die infektionszahlen bis dahin nicht
wieder angestiegen sind sagt theo koll
in berlin
theo heute herzlichen dank dafür und
dann gucken wir jetzt zu einem kleinen
grenzübergang der seit heute wieder
geöffnet hat und so patricia schäfer sie
ist an der deutsch österreichischen
grenze in bayerisch gmain patricia guten
namen wie ist denn die situation dort im
moment die vielen leute kommen da jetzt
drüber
ja es ist christiane bisschen weniger
geworden in den letzten minuten aber den
tag überall hat man doch hier einen
regen aber ruhigen grenzverkehr gehabt
einen kleinen denn nach wie vor gilt
diese grenzöffnung hier zwischen
bayerisch gmain und groß klein nur für
anrainer also die anrainergemeinden und
auch nur für die leute mit den richtigen
papieren man muss also vorweisen können
dass man pendler ist oder dass man
familie auf der anderen seite hat neu
ist dass auch schüler passieren dürfen
dass es interessant weil die müssen
sonst einen 15 kilometer langen umweg
nehmen und nachts wird dichtgemacht
hinter mir dieser blaue grenzzaun der
bis heute früh um 6 zu war wird wieder
geschlossen um 20 uhr und ab samstag
soll es dann nur noch stichprobenartige
grenzkontrollen geben aber bisher ist
das nur eine politische willensbekundung
klare handlungsanweisungen haben die
grenzpolizisten auf beiden seiten noch
nicht darauf wird gewartet die
verordnung wird noch geschrieben es ist
also dringend davon abzuraten
aus jux und dollerei das mal
ausprobieren zu wollen wir haben hier
auch schon einige leute gesehen die
zurückgewiesen wurden
live aus dem bayerisch gmain großklein
exakt herzlichen dank patricia dafür
und dann gehen wir jetzt über die grenze
nach österreich rein das land fährt ja
langsam wieder hoch am freitag gab die
gastronomie ganz öffnen ende des monats
dann auch die hotels man hofft auf gäste
natürlich auch aus deutschland und
versucht verlorenes vertrauen wieder
zurückzugewinnen
britta hilpert bei obernberg auf
österreichischer seite merkt man wie
sehr die alte grenzenlose normalität
ersehnt wird man muss als deutscher
immer noch einen guten grund haben um
nach österreich zu fahren ein paar
wochen noch belege diskussionen nicht
immer gelingt ich hab mir gedacht ist
kann ich meine enkel und meine tochter
und sohn wiedersehen
jetzt wird noch nicht über den berg ganz
geöffnet ab mitte juni kann man
uneingeschränkt nach österreich fahren
wenn man denn will
denn in orten wie spül- oder sölden
steckten sich tausende in bergbahnen
oder beim apres ski an viele urlauber
klagen wegen des mangelhaften
krisenmanagements allein in sölden 250
sowie der bürgermeister hier werben
viele in tirol um vertrauen
im rückblick ist sicher nicht alles rund
gelaufen
das werden wir aufarbeiten es ist ein
versprechen doch was folgt daraus für
den massentourismus amberg mir fällt
nichts ein was man im süden neu erfinden
könnte um einen tourismus zu machen
corona aber zwingt dazu überall sorgt
man nun für mehr abstand masken und
hygiene
österreich hat mit drastischen maßnahmen
infektionszahlen gedrückt aber nun meint
die chefin des weißen rössl am
wolfgangsee braucht sie gäste jetzt wird
es zeit dass die wirtschaft auch wieder
am leben gelassen wird und nicht
umgebracht wird
tourismus ist in österreich ein
wesentlicher wirtschaftszweig gegen
korona kommen kaum gäste aus übersee
man zählt auf die von nebenan am 15 juni
können die deutschen kommen wenn sie
wollen
eine ausführliche reportage aus
österreich gibt es heute abend im
auslandsjournal hier im zdf um 22 uhr 30
solange das virus da ist reisen wir mit
risiko sagt die eu-kommission und hat
sich richtlinien überlegt die den
sommerurlaub trotzdem möglich machen
sollen
auch brüssel empfiehlt die grenzen zu
öffnen schrittweise und abhängig von der
infektionszahlen maske tragen und
abstand halten sollen pflicht seien auf
dem weg in den urlaub und vor ort zum
beispiel durch weniger hotelgäste
beimessen
und am pool freie mittel sitze im
flugzeug fordert die eu-kommission aber
nicht gegen eine solche pflicht hatten
sich einige airlines gewährt und dann
hören wir den zuständigen eu-kommissar
der sagt wir werden definitiv im sommer
eine touristensaison haben frage an
stefan leifert für uns in brüssel
stefan welche garantien kann die eu
ihren bürgern denn da geben ja
garantieren kann brüssel natürlich für
nichts aber die eu kommission hat heute
zumindest einen katalog mit maßstäben
vorgelegt nach denen die einzelnen
mitgliedsländer jetzt entscheiden sollen
welche urlaubsregionen geöffnet werden
können und welches welche nicht erstes
kriterium natürlich wie hoch ist noch
das infektionsgeschehen das ist klar
zweites kriterium dann können die
veranstalter also hotels airlines
ferienpark sicherstellen dass die
urlauber dort die hygiene und
abstandsregeln einhalten können das
schließt dann zum beispiel gruppen und
massen reisen dieses jahr wirklich aus
und das dritte kriterium die frage wie
ist die gesundheitsversorgung einer
region gibt es genug krankenhäuser und
ärzte vor zwei dingen will die
eu-kommission die urlauber bewahren zum
einen vor diskriminierung also ein land
beispielsweise österreich sollen nicht
sagen können wir wollen dieses jahr nur
deutsche urlauber empfangen und das
letzte ist ein verbraucherschutz aspekt
sollte eine reise gecancelt werden vom
veranstalter dann soll der kunde das
recht haben zu wählen zwischen einer bar
erstattung oder einem gutschein all das
zeigt eine normale sitzung steht europa
wirklich nicht befolgen stefan vielen
dank reisen 2020 das bleibt also eine
besondere herausforderung für die
reisebüros ihnen brechen die umsätze weg
und sie demonstrieren auch heute wieder
für mehr staatliche hilfen für die
reiseveranstalter
hier bahnt sich ein massiver verlust von
arbeitsplätzen an etwa bei der tui
und natürlich für die urlauber selbst
die haben viele fragen reisen ja oder
nein und wo kann man überhaupt hin
romanesco war exotik urlaub unter palmen
eher unwahrscheinlich die nachbarländer
als ziel dagegen nicht mehr gänzlich
unmöglich und trotzdem für manche
reiselustigen reicht die vorsichtige
öffnung unter auflagen noch nicht um den
sommerurlaub jetzt fest zu machen
ich kann jetzt nichts planen weil es
steht nichts fest und ich weiß auch
nicht wohin ich erreichen kann
etwas konkretes steht werde ich wieder
anfangen zu gucken wo man hin wenn ich
ein wohl am fahrer dann möchte ich die
hotelbar sitzen cocktail trinken mich
frei bewegen und nicht von jemandem
bedient werden der wunsch hat das finde
ich es kein für mich kann nur noch für
die tourismuswirtschaft die
zurückhaltung existenzbedrohend in
mehreren deutschen städten wurde heute
protestiert noch prägen stornierungen
und umbuchungen das geschäft
entsprechend vorsichtig die reaktion
hierauf die politik sein wie viele
verbraucher wie viele gäste werden
reisen wollen es herrscht eine sehr hohe
verunsicherung ist ein leichter
silberstreif aber es macht die
notwendigkeit von finanziellen hilfen
zuschüssen und beihilfen in keiner weise
obsolet auch die großen müssen einbußen
hinnehmen
die tui plant 8000 stellen einzusparen
oder nicht zu besetzen um die
sommersaison zu retten braucht es
schnell weitere schritte es muss relativ
früh zum sommer losgehen dass wir auch
sommergeschäft noch sehen es wäre auch
sehr sinnvoll gemahl für kunden die
sicherheit erzeugen könnte das die auch
wissen dass sie fliegen können der druck
auf die politik bleibt hoch sollen die
strände europas diesen sommer nicht
komplett leerbleiben
mehr dazu im zdf spezial corona krise
lockerung der grenzkontrollen
das läuft gleich nach und dann kommen
wir jetzt zu unseren blick auf die
zahlen für deutschland die täglichen
neuansteckungen bleiben unter 1000 im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
steckten sich 880 menschen pro tag mit
dem corona virus an
insgesamt sind aktuell mehr als 173.000
infektionen durch tests bestätigt davon
gelten fast 149.000 als genesen 7780
menschen sind in verbindung mit dem
virus gestorben
die situation in brasilien ist deutlich
dramatischer fast 900 tote wurden dort
allein gestern gemeldet das virus
verbreitet sich rasant so sieht die
kurve der infektionen in brasilien aus
nur eine richtung immer weiter nach
oben der rechtspopulistische präsident
ja ihre bolz onavo wehrt sich weiter
gegen korona einschränkungen vor allem
ärzte und pfleger fühlen sich im stich
gelassen christoph rath berichtet jeder
name ein schicksal verstorbene
kolleginnen und kollegen
es ist ein einsamer protest von jenen
die sich an der front im kampf gegen
korona allein gelassen fühlen
sie zahlen einen hohen preis nirgendwo
auf der welt ist ihre arbeit so
gefährlich wie in brasilien
leider ist brasilien das land in dem die
meisten pflegekräfte ihr leben verlieren
wir haben sogar mehr tote als die länder
die noch mehr corona fälle haben das
bereitet uns große sorgen schwarze
ballons als erinnerung an die toten
kollegen weise für die die weiterkämpfen
im ganzen land protestiert das
krankenhauspersonal gegen ignoranz
sorglosigkeit und schlechte
arbeitsbedingungen
jeder der ins krankenhaus kommt könnte
mit cupid 19 infiziert seien daher
sollten alle mitarbeiter die mit
patienten in kontakt kommen
schutzausrüstung haben
doch das ist immer noch nicht der fall
während das gesundheitswesen kollabiert
versuchen die regionalen gouverneure die
steil nach oben schnellen die
infektionsrate mit quarantänemaßnahmen
einzudämmen
doch es regt sich protest wir müssen das
land wieder öffnen die leute sterben
nicht an kuwait 19
sie sterben weil sie zu hause vor hunger
befeuert werden diese ansichten von
präsident ball zu nahrung der das virus
weiter herunter spielt wohl szenario hat
erreicht dass der umgang mit corona zu
einer ideologischen frage geworden ist
die das land spaltet und so eine
koordinierte bekämpfung des virus
sabotiert brasilien streitet während die
zahl der infizierten und der toten
ungebremst in die höhe schnellt zurück
nach deutschland die schlachthöfe bei
uns gelten für tierschützer und
arbeitsrechtler schon seit langem als
problemzonen in corona zweiten haben die
fragwürdigen bedingungen unter denen die
beschäftigten dort arbeiten und wohnen
verheerende folgen
es gibt immer mehr infektionen in immer
mehr schlachthöfen niedersachsens
ministerpräsident stephan weil wirft
teilen der fleischindustrie zitat
komplett verantwortungslos
verhalten vor die politik kündigt
konsequenzen an dominik müller russe der
wiesenhof geflügel schlachtbetrieb bei
straubing in bayern in der kantine
werden seit heute mittag 1000
mitarbeiter getestet nachdem mehrere
arbeiter an corona erkrankt sind in
immer mehr schlachthöfen in immer mehr
bundesländern greift das virus um sich
alleine bei müller fleisch in baden
württemberg sind 400 von rund 1100
mitarbeitern positiv getestet wir haben
die geschäftsleitung klipp und klar
aufgefordert dass das geschäftsmodell
wie es derzeit stattfindet nicht nur bei
müller fleisch sondern die gesamten
fleischbranche so nicht weitergehen kann
und haben müller fleisch verpflichtet
bis diese woche donnerstag das komplette
geschäftsmodell zu überarbeiten im sinne
von hygiene und infekt zu einer branche
ein geschäftsmodell in der kritik unter
ausbeuterischen bedingungen würden vor
allem osteuropäische arbeiter auf
engstem raum zusammen arbeiten und auch
lieben ohne chance mindestabstände etwa
einhalten zu können
die fleischindustrie heute thema im
bundestag der arbeitsminister verspricht
schärfere regeln es ist zeit für
klartext und verantwortung wir werden
aufräumen müssen und wir werden
aufräumen mit diesen verhältnissen meine
damen und herren ich bitte sie
parteiübergreifend als arbeitsminister
um unterstützung die branche sieht sich
zu unrecht am pranger
deutschlands größter schlachtbetrieb
heute also zuallererst würde ich mal
erwarten dass man sich an den tisch
setzt und nicht drauf haut das
populistischen stück weit der
arbeitsminister erfordert außerdem in
ihrer kontrolle
am montag will er ein schärferes konzept
vorliegen vor allem was die
unterbringung der arbeiter betrifft so
viel zunächst zum thema corona weitere
wichtige nachrichten der präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts andreas
voßkuhle weist die kritik am urteil zu
den ezb anleihekäufen zurück der zeit
sagte er verfassungsgerichte sein
legitimiert und verpflichtet
einzuschreiten
in seltenen ausnahmefällen bei besonders
gravierenden kompetenz verletzungen der
europäischen institutionen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hatte sich
gegen den europäischen gerichtshof
gestellt und die billionenschweren
aufkäufe von staatsanleihen der
euroländer durch die ezb als teilweise
verfassung
niedrig eingestuft drohnen sollen uns
künftig den alltag massiv erleichtern
etwa in der landwirtschaft beim einsatz
von pflanzenschutz und düngemitteln
helfen könnten sie auch arbeiten die
schäden an hochspannungsnetz finden
müssen oder bei der wartung der
windräder vor der küste mit den regeln
dafür hat sich heute das bundeskabinett
beschäftigt christiane hübscher fasst
zusammen die drohne für die
pressekonferenz landet pünktlich der
bundesverkehrsminister will mehr von den
kleinen unbemannten fluggeräten sehen
und gibt für drohnen projekte mit neuen
geschäftsideen 29 millionen euro
fördergelder keiner braucht angst haben
darum dass sie jetzt neue fluggeräte am
himmel zu sehen sind sondern wir setzen
den rechtlichen rahmen medifly die
transport drohne aus hamburg braucht für
fünf kilometer zwischen zwei
krankenhäusern nur zehn minuten in der
luft völlig automatisiert sie haben die
möglichkeit mit einer drohne
gewebeproben oder blutkonserven corona
tests oder einige medikamente schnell
von einem ort zum anderen zu
transportieren
spanien setzt drohnen im kampf gegen
korona ein zur großflächigen
desinfektion von städten und schon bald
könnten die pakete auch hier per
luftpost kommen ein wachsender markt
es ist keineswegs so dass der markt
schon an china verloren ist alles
konditorei kommt und unsere unternehmen
kann markt haben wir haben 400 drohen
firmen in deutschland die im
durchschnitt 12 mitarbeit zu haben noch
ist er viel zu regulieren vom drohnen
führerschein über die luftsicherheit bis
zum schutz der privatsphäre
doch science fiction ist es nicht mehr
wir sind schon sehr sehr real unterwegs
ich möchte ganz ganz konkrete
anwendungen im live betrieb in den
nächsten drei jahren sehen echte flug
taxis mit passagieren an bord brauchen
wohl noch etwas länger gehören aber auch
fest zum verkehrskonzept der zukunft
zuckerbäcker kaffeehaus oder beisel sind
in wien immer einen besuch wert und
damit die wiener das jetzt auch wieder
kräftig machen hat die stadt eine
besondere idee sie verteilt gutscheine
an die haushalte wer allein lebt bekommt
25 euro familien 50 euro zum einkehren
egal ob sachertorte oder wiener
schnitzel es ist dann vielleicht den
gastwirten soll so nach der korona pause
geholfen werden einzige auflage für
alkohol gilt der qubo nicht den grünen
veltliner zum essen muss jeder selbst
bezahlen
die leute zahlen sie lauten 12 17 22 21
43 46 und die superzahl 4 weitere
gewinnzahlen wie immer auf lotto zdf de
oder im zdf text auf seite 55 7
noch bleibt kühl aber in den nächsten
tagen steigen die temperaturen mehr dazu
gleich beim wetter mit osten telli ich
empfehle ihnen das heute journal gegen
22 uhr mit der kollegin marietta slomka
und morgen gibt es uns wieder punkt 19
uhr für heute aber erstmal in allen
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
ein schwimmbad und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter ein großes und orts festes
hoch bestimmt im prinzip unser wetter
denn auf seiner ostseite kommt hier
immer wieder kühlere luft von norden her
von süden aber auch mal feuchte luft und
dann gibt es eben viele wolken und auch
regen zum beispiel in der kommenden
nacht im süden vor allem durchaus
längerer regen ansonsten sind schauer im
norden unterwegs die werden allmählich
weniger temperaturen liegen zwischen
minus ein grad im norden und 8 grad ganz
im süden deutschlands morgen in der
nordhälfte überwiegend freundlich kann
man sagen hier zeigt sich die sonne
häufiger nach süden hin zunächst viele
wolken mit regen und dann wird das
allmählich weniger bei temperaturen von
zehn grad an der nordsee und 16 grad an
rhein und main in den nächsten tagen
wird es allmählich trockener am freitag
allerdings noch im süden regen und im
norden schauer bei 7 bis 17 grad und
dann wird es wärmer damit einen schönen
abends